hey how's everyone doing today we're
going to analyze elon musk's appearance
on the lex friedman podcast specifically
we're going to look at the part where
elon talks about the tesla autopilot and
to a certain degree also the tesla bot
we've previously analyzed the talk by
andrei carpati about what kind of
architectures and so on goes into the
tesla self-driving system and this
naturally progresses over time so elon's
going to drop some more hints here what
exactly is going on under the hood we're
gonna dive right in let me know if you
enjoy talk analyses or not uh who knows
all i know is that whenever you put elon
musk on something you get insanely many
clicks so thank you for that
autopilot
tesla
uh i love how they go like autopilot and
then both are like
yeah as if they're saying like yeah like
like like that's ever gonna work as you
might know autopilot is a bit behind
schedule it's been promised again and
again and again especially the full
self-driving uh sort of autopilot but
there also has been insanely much
progress like no one is pushing that
people have told me you know other car
companies are doing it as well yeah but
no one's kind of pushing it quite like
that and sure there are some risks to to
go along with rolling out alpha and beta
versions just to users but yeah i mean
come on and so there was a natural
skepticism when i first drove a tesla
with uh the initial system based on
mobile eye yeah i thought there's no way
the first one i got in i thought there's
no way this car could
maintain um like stay in lane and create
a comfortable experience so
okay so i didn't know that the first
system was based on on mobile eye which
is interesting because at one point
during my phd we got visit from a
researcher who also worked on mobileye i
won't name the researcher here because i
i might be about to tell some stuff that
would get them into trouble but they
showed us a video of themselves in a car
i remember this vividly and uh the the
car was just kind of opened the whole
dashboard was open all the cables were
like hanging out and going into some
laptop that was just kind of dangling on
sort of the the middle of the car you
know where the stick i don't know what
what you call that stuff in in english
it was like a super instable setup and
you know a cables flying around there
any everywhere and then the camera kind
of pans up and you can see that car is
on the highway like middle of the
highway cars here cars here and just
driving itself you see the steering
wheel no hands on it and uh it was
insane like when i when i saw this i
never expected technology to be this far
already and yes i know in the 70s and
80s people have done self-driving on
highways but still for someone to trust
the system enough to essentially sit
there and let the system steer the car
based on nothing but cameras was insane
this system is just the beginning like
the the baseline for the tesla system i
i didn't know that and i thought it was
an interesting story to tell i was
already super impressed by the mobilize
system yet as you will see that this has
been surpassed a lot what are some
insights you've gained over those
five six years of autopilot about the
problem of autonomous driving so
you leaped in
having some sort of first principles
kinds of intuitions but nobody knows
how difficult
the problem like i thought the
self-driving problem would be hard but
it was harder than i thought it's not
like i thought it'd be easy i thought
it'd be very hard but it was
actually way harder than than even that
so
i mean what it comes down to at the end
of the day is to solve self-driving
uh you have to solve
uh
you you basically
need to recreate
what you what humans do to drive which
is humans drive with
optical sensors eyes and biological
neural nets
um and so in order to that that's how
the entire road system is designed to
work with with uh
basically passive optical
and neural nets
um it biologically um and now that we
need to it so for actually for full self
driving to work we have to recreate that
in digital form
um so we have to um so the argument here
is i guess um if you if you want to
solve this self-driving problem you need
to essentially do what humans do and i'm
not exactly buying this argument like
just because humans only drive with
vision especially just because humans
have you know neural networks we also
must use neural networks that seems a
bit shady but there's a point to it
right that the whole road system and
cars and whatnot are designed around
human capabilities and vision and audio
and stuff like this and therefore yes
it's good to drive if you have like a
radar and a lidar and whatnot that's
additional sensors but you're not going
to get around building in the human
sensors as well so a car that just
drives mainly on radar or lidar is
probably good at you know avoiding
obstacles that are just on the road
somewhere but it's not going to be able
to see any signs it's not going to be
able to sort of make sense of the of the
world visually understand what's going
on and things like this which you know
if something's speeding along coming
along and you can anticipate it by
vision it's uh probably a lot a lot
better than you having to somehow detect
it on the radar so i think that's a fair
point right here but you know humans
having neural network therefore we must
have neural network i'm not super sure
that's that's uh valid how much game
theoretic kind of stuff needs to be
involved you know at a four-way stop
sign
you know our as humans when we drive our
actions affect the world like sure it
changes how others behave most
autonomous driving if you
you're usually just responding
um to the scene
as opposed to like really um asserting
yourself in the scene do you think
i think these so i think i think these
could these sort of control control
logic conundrums are not are not the
hard part
um
the
you know
let's see um
what do you think is the hard part in
this whole
um beautiful complex problem so it's a
lot of freaking software man
a lot of smart lines of code um
for sure in order to have
um
create an accurate vector space
so
like if you're you're coming from image
space which is
so i think elon's gonna make the point
here that uh what lex's concern is that
you know there's a lot of game theoretic
stuff and he mentions the four-way
four-way crossroads and then you sort of
have to communicate who goes first who
goes last and so on and elon says that
that's not that's not the big problem in
self-driving he's gonna make the point
that once you do have an accurate
representation of the world once you
know where every car is and so on what
every sign means that you can figure
this stuff out easily and i think i
agree at least the number of situations
you can broadly cover with programming
heuristics is sort of countable and i
would guess that that would work though
i'm not super sure if that goes all the
way because there is game theoretic
stuff like you can you know change a
lane based on the fact that you know
kind of game theoretically that other
people won't sort of cut you off while
you do it because they'd crash their car
and so on which you can't just know by
looking at their speeds and the
positions of the cars sort of the
anticipation of how everyone else is
going to react in certain situations is
i think a big part of driving and also a
big part of sort of predicting dangers
so i'm not super sure if you can just
hard code all of that but i think saying
that you know the perception problem is
conceptually the harder problem because
for the perception problem there isn't
even an approach with regular
programming right you have to sort of
learn it and yes if you if you make a
mistake in the perception problem that's
going to have vast downstream effects so
i i do agree here that probably the
self-driving problem might at least at
this time largely be a computer vision
or let's say uh not only vision but sort
of world understanding perception
problem after that it becomes sort of
easier once you uh have an accurate
vector space um
the control problem is similar to that
of a video game like a grand theft auto
cyberpunk uh
yeah
yes i want my i want my traffic
management sys i want my self-driving
system to be the the one from cyberpunk
please
oh lord help us please um yeah i mean
point taken right uh what elon calls
vector space right here i guess you
you'd sort of call a scene understanding
a scene graph you know any anything like
this essentially where are the objects
in the scene sort of what's their
position their momentum i guess you know
where are the signs what do they mean
where are the traffic lights all of this
kind of stuff once you have that the the
problem of sort of planning ahead what
you should do becomes probably
relatively easy at least compared to
that perception problem like when's the
last time you looked right and left at
you know or and rearward um or even
diagonally
you know forward
to actually refresh your vector space
so you're glancing around and what your
mind is doing is is is trying to distill
um the relevant vectors basically
objects with a position and motion
uh and
and and and then uh editing that down to
the least amount that's necessary for
you to drive
it does seem to be able to
uh edit it down or compress it even
further into things like concepts so
it's not it's like it goes beyond the
human mind it seems to go sometimes
beyond vector space
to sort of space of concepts to where
you'll see a thing it's no longer
represented spatially somehow it's
almost like a concept that you should be
aware of like if this is a school zone
you'll remember that
as a concept which is a
that's a really good good point so elon
made the the point essentially that what
your brain is doing and therefore what
you know the the ai should be doing is
take all that information and build what
elon calls this this vector space which
is as he said sort of objects and their
motions but lex goes a step further and
says well you also know sort of that
this is a school zone and in a school
zone not only should i be driving slower
but there might be children around so i
need to be sort of careful i i in fact
adapt my attention and my vision on
different things than if something like
than if it's a highway and i think that
is as of yet probably not considered by
these these ai systems i'm pretty sure
they that the input feed is all the same
no matter whether it's a school zone or
whether it is a highway of course
there's different things us humans have
a limited amount of attention and elon
just pointed out sort of all the ways in
which your system is screwed up like
blind spots and yada yada and that might
be the reason why we have to sort of
focus our attention on different things
and you know depending on where we are
so it could be that the machines are
just you know they don't care they can
always pay attention to everything and
therefore this is not a concern to them
i'm not entirely convinced by this uh
the the sort of guiding of attention and
sort of the top-down feedback loop to
the lower systems i think is as of yet
completely missing from the ai systems
i'm not sure actually um maybe maybe
they do sort of feed let's say they know
they're in a school zone they know you
know the speed limit is such and such
and or there's a construction site maybe
they feed sort of embeddings of this
stuff into
sort of the vision networks and the
vision networks might be able to adjust
uh sort of their their attention
patterns not that probably they don't
use attention they probably use con nets
or so but it would be interesting to see
if that was happening i would be very
surprised if it was though so not sure
this might be a fundamental limitation
it might be that without this the
driving problem is essentially
unsolvable or or there's there's major
hurdles that can't be overcome it could
also be that just you know the machines
can always pay attention to everything
and therefore it just doesn't matter
you saw that there were some kids about
to cross the road
in front of the truck now you can no
longer see the kids but you you need to
be able but you would now know okay
those kids are probably gonna pass by
the truck and cross the road
even though you cannot see them so you
have to have um
memory uh
you need to remember there were kids
there and you need to have some forward
prediction of what their
uh position will be it's a really hard
time of relevance so
i mean yeah exactly so they're going to
talk about occlusions here occlusions uh
detecting occluded objects and so on but
i think elon's point is bigger than that
you need to have a forward predicting
model in order to do the self-driving
you know solve the self-driving problem
to a realistic degree and here i would
you know challenge this earlier
statement that once you have the vector
space the problem is sort of you know
not that hard i think this particular
part of the remaining problem is
actually quite hard in itself because
it's not like you can just calculate the
nash equilibrium of self-driving and
then assume that everyone's acting
rationally you have to sort of take into
account all the human factors right here
and how you expect other humans to act
be that pedestrians or other drivers or
anything like this yeah i think this is
another area this sort of forward
prediction where neural net or in
general machine learning is going to
make a big difference and then as i said
i'd be wondering if there is sort of a
top-down feedback loop that as you're
predicting forward you're going to
change sort of the perception pipeline
on the fly or not
but like let's say you you're parked at
light and you and you saw
you use a pedestrian example that people
were waiting to cross the
across the road
and you can't you can't quite see them
because of an occlusion
uh
but they might wait for a minute before
the light changes for them to cross the
road you still need to to remember that
that's where they were
and that they're probably going to cross
the road type of thing um so even if
that exceeds your
your your time based memory it should
not exceed your space
memory
and i just think the data engine side of
that so getting the data to learn all
the concepts that you're saying now is
an incredible process it's this
iterative process of just
wait and i i just think so so what um so
what he said right there i think is is
quite important as well you know you can
probably understand it in the concept if
you do reinforcement learning let's say
you did reinforcement learning in this
thing typically in reinforcement
learning we have a finite amount of time
where you can go back over time and
still be able to do back propagation
especially if you're at like a high
frame rate like these
these systems operate right here that's
not going to be a long time it's not
going to be a minute of real time and
therefore yes if you need to learn to
remember something like they're
pedestrians right there and they're
still there a minute later because all
the lights were red that is going to be
quite a bit of a problem and a challenge
in itself sort of learning to remember
things is a long-standing challenge in
reinforcement learning and you probably
be better off sort of coding all the
objects in this what what elon calls the
vector space so so understand the scene
and then explicitly representing each
object that's there rather than having
the neural networks learn everything
from perception i think the data engine
side of that so getting the data to
learn all the concepts that you're
saying now is an incredible process it's
this iterative process of just
it's this this hydrant out of many
internet yeah
we're changing the name to something
else okay i'm sure it would be equally
as
rick and morty like
yeah we've re-architected the neural net
uh the neural nets in the cars so many
times it's crazy
oh so every time there's a new major
version you'll rename it to something
more ridiculous or
uh or memorable and beautiful sorry not
ridiculous of course
if you see the full the full like uh
array of neural nets that that that are
operating in the cards it kind of
boggles the mind there's so there's so
many layers it's crazy um
i mean what what is what is he actually
saying
here
it's hard to decipher elon because
obviously he's not you know a deep
learning engineer so he sort of probably
gets like the the pitch from from andre
and you know some diagrams or something
like this but as of now we don't know if
there are many neural nets but it's
unlikely because he says like it's it's
mind-bogglingly many and you'd have to
sort of train all of them i couldn't
really imagine how you'd put like
mind-bogglingly many neural networks
into a system like this so i'm gonna
guess that they have a couple
and these are just kind of big and
complicated and that's exactly what we
saw in in karpati's talk when he
explained how they how they go vision
only and and so on if you haven't seen
this watch my analysis of that he's
about to explain a bit more in depth of
what's going on we started off with
uh
simple neural nets that were uh
basically
image recognition on a single frame
from a single camera
and
then uh trying to knit those together
with
it you know it with the
c
i should say we we we're really
primarily running c here because c plus
plus is
too much overhead and we have our own c
compiler
so to get maximum performance we
actually wrote rotor and c compiler and
are continuing to optimize rc compiler
uh for uh maximum efficiency in fact
we've just recently
uh done a new rev on a c compiler that
will compile directly to our autopilot
hardware do you want to compile the
whole thing down
i mean he's going to talk about two
things kind of interleaved right here
that have on the surface not too much to
do with each other so apparently there
is a c compiler that compiles directly
to the hardware which makes sense right
these cars have the property that you
have to be super duper efficient and
power saving and whatnot and you know
running python on top of that might just
you know the overhead of that might just
be
too much you can in fact save a lot of
energy a lot of time and so on by going
building a compiler that uses the
hardware as optimally as possible now
that being said this has little to do
with you know how you build the neural
network system other than the neural
networks will be faster if you compile
compile them down correctly
and and so there's actually a lot of
work done by
some very talented software engineers at
tesla that
uh at a very foundational level to
improve the efficiency of compute and
how we use the
the trip accelerators uh which are
basically um
you know uh doing matrix math dot
products uh like a brazilian dot
products you know and it's like what
what what are neural nets it's like
computer-wise like 99 dot products
so
yeah i mean he he's he's obviously uh
correct right here though it has to be
said you know for anyone who's listening
to this your
neural network isn't slow because
because you you don't have the right
compiler it is true that if you do it
correctly you compile your network down
to like a format that is optimal for
some hardware and you run it with you
know the correct libraries and and you
set up everything correctly you can
probably get like maybe if you did if
you did it terribly wrong and then you
do it terribly right you can get
up to a 10x speed up i would guess you
know 5x 10x speed up something like this
best case however usually usually the
first thing you should investigate is
whether or not the architecture you're
using is the correct one you can get
like many many more times a speed up by
simply changing the architecture to
something more appropriate so elon says
this here because obviously this is the
last step and you know they need to they
need to get every every millisecond they
can out of these systems but just for
most people listening this is sort of
the the sugar the icing on the cake you
should first care about the cake and try
to make your architecture you know more
optimal maybe use less layers or
anything like this change from this
operation to that operation analyze your
bottlenecks and only once you have
everything through and you have the
exact model you want then you can care
about you know doing all the engineering
things
one of the things we're um moving
towards now is no post-processing of the
image through the um
uh
the image signal processor so
um
like for what happens for
cameras is that almost all cameras is
they
um
there's a lot of post processing done in
order to make pictures look pretty
uh and so we don't care about pictures
looking pretty um we we just want the
data we so we're removing just raw
photon counts
so the system will
like the
image that
that the computer sees is actually much
more than what
you see if you're represented on a
camera it's got much more data
and even in very low light conditions
you can see that there's a small photon
count difference between
you know
this spot here and that's about there
which means that so it can see in the
dark incredibly well
um because it can detect these tiny
differences in photon counts
like much better than you
possibly imagined
um so
and i mean that that is again like that
is a third issue next to the
the c compiler and what the neural
networks do is essentially saying that
if you remove the post processing within
the the camera sensors that are usually
built into let's say cameras that you
could buy on the market then you you get
the raw data and since you don't have to
look at the pictures the raw data is
much more useful than the post-process
data since it's a machine anyway that
analyzes the signal and therefore you
might as well make it machine friendly i
think it is a good lesson for maybe
other fields as well to think about you
know what parts of the pipeline are just
there to make it you know because
because humans are involved and try to
remove those but you know it doesn't
really add to what's the a what's the
deal with the neural networks which i
think was the original question here and
then we also save uh 13 milliseconds on
a latency uh
so
um from removing the post processing on
the image yes yeah it's like um
because we've got you know eight cameras
and and then there's uh
roughly i don't know one and a half
milliseconds or so
maybe 1.6 milliseconds of latency um
for each camera and so
like
uh um
going to just
uh
basically bypassing the image processor
uh gets us back 13 milliseconds of
latency which is important
um
yeah i think this you know besides
getting the raw data this is also again
they need to squeeze out sort of the
last mile here or the last milliseconds
here and this is another thing they they
can practically do
so getting rid of jitter is extremely
important
and that affects your control decisions
and all those kinds of things
okay
um yeah the car is just gonna
fundamentally maneuver better with lower
jitter um
you've got it yeah
the the cars will maneuver with
superhuman ability and reaction time
much faster than a human
i mean i think over time the
autopilot full self driving will be
capable of maneuvers that um
you know
uh
you know are far more than what like
james bond could do in like the best
movie type of thing that's exactly what
i was imagining in my mind as you said
um it's like an impossible maneuvers
that a human couldn't do you know so
well okay it's it's it's it's two things
impossible maneuvers are impossible and
things that humans could do you know are
things that humans could do i also i
have no doubt that at one point in the
near future self-driving cars will be
able to do things that humans couldn't
do the question is more are there going
to be things that humans do that the
course couldn't do right or can't do
because that's the actual gap you're
trying to close you know look at boston
dynamics or so if you hard code stuff
and you have extremely extremely good
sensors and actuators you can do many
things that humans couldn't do but on
the other hand you know it's the things
that humans can do that the machines
can't and those are the problem
well let me ask sort of uh looking back
the six years looking out into the
future based on your current
understanding how hard do you think this
this full self-driving problem when do
you think tesla will solve level four
fsd
i think elon gets asked this question
every year and every year he says next
year so um
i mean it's looking quite likely that it
will be next year
this is the thing with elon musk he
always promises things like next year or
on ridiculously short amounts of time
and i wonder how long it's going to take
for people to to just you know stop
believing him i guess many people
already did but it's still you know a
thing to consider that on one hand
obviously if you do it too much then
people are simply going to say oh well
probably in five years if he says next
year but on the other hand he's also
able to sort of it's a motivating thing
it's it's a cool thing it it drives
momentum and that itself accelerates the
developments of these things people
being ready to just flip on a beta
version and so on it's a bit insane but
i do think is optimism and a little bit
salesmanship also a lot of benefits
besides the the obvious negatives
um so the interventions
you know per million miles has been
dropping
dramatically at some point the
and and that
trend looks like it happens next year is
the the the
probability of an accident on fsd uh is
uh less than that of the average human
and then and then significantly less
than that of the average human um
so
it certainly
appears like we will get there next year
there's a lot of hedging going on here
but you know you can this is this is
actually a nice method i think of of
making these types of predictions you
see that the rate of disengagements is
dropping at a at a certain speed you can
extrapolate maybe a little bit and say
look you know here's going to be the the
sort of threshold where we're better
than a human i think that's quite a
sober analysis if done correctly and i
also think people who are you know it's
obviously good to be skeptical of you
know fully self-driving systems but on
the other hand you also have to think if
they're a lot better than humans it
makes makes total sense right it also
makes total sense to have them and not
engage them all the time right there
might still be situations you want to
drive yourself the question is a little
bit can you just continue the trend or
is there a sort of an okay you solve the
easy problems and that is what makes the
rates of disengagements go down now
but now come the more and more hard
problems and sort of it gets
exponentially harder to continue that
trend in which case we're not going to
be there for a long time then there's
going to be a case of okay we now have
to prove this to regulators and prove it
to you know and and we we want a
standard that is not just equivalent to
a human but
uh much better than the average human i
think it's got to be at least two or
three times uh higher
safety than a human yeah probably more
like ten like knowing you know no
regulators and and how the public
perceives these types of things of
course right now they're they're cool
but then it's really easy to publicize
in a few accidents that few stupid
accidents that happen if you build
machine learning systems for the real
world they are going to make stupid
mistakes it doesn't matter how accurate
they are on average they're going to
make stupid mistakes that a human would
never do and people are just going to
point at it and never forget that one
instance and i think it's it's pretty
easy to sort of scare people publicizing
those kinds of things and therefore yeah
you have to be like massively better
than humans i i agree here uh there is a
some fundamental like leap that really
deserves the 11. i mean that's a pretty
cool number yeah yeah
11 would be
a single stack for all you know one
stack to rule them all um
and uh
but but there's just some really
fundamental
uh
neural net architecture changes that are
that will allow for
uh much more capability but but
you know at first they're going to have
issues so
like we have this working on like sort
of alpha software and it's good but it's
uh
it's it's it it's basically taking a
whole bunch of c c plus plus code and
and and deleting a massive amount of c
first plus go and replacing it with the
neural net and you know andre uh makes
this point a lot which is like neural
nets like kind of eating software
so it's interesting what elon says right
here this upcoming version 11 of the
tesla software seems to have kind of a
rewrite in what he calls the creation of
the vector space and specifically he
says you replace a whole bunch of c and
c plus plus code with neural networks
and uh i guess what what that means is
that they used to have certain
heuristics for what he calls creating
the vector space right and remember
creating the vector space means scene
understanding so what objects exist
where are they how are they moving and
so on and you want to get that out of
your your cameras and whatever other
sensors you have so it seems like until
now they had a bunch of neural networks
that would do you know their their stuff
i can imagine they had maybe single
frame neural networks or kind of short
frames one after another neural networks
that would recognize sort of bounding
boxing the objects in the image and then
they would use sort of an algorithm
heuristic algorithm that they wrote
themselves to stitch that together over
time maybe they use algorithms to do
some kind of inferences like what he
mentioned with the object tracking and
so on and it seems to be that what they
want to do is just end to end train one
big neural network that just does it all
you input all of the sensor data let's
say from you know not only just right
now but you know from the from the
recent past you just input it all in
there and the neural network will spit
out this finished vector space this
finished scene understanding graph and
this obviously you can see where it
comes from this has been the story of
deep learning so far replacing more and
more classical heuristics with an
end-to-end learning system and it also
matches exactly with what elon is saying
namely that right now it doesn't seem to
work quite well yet but in time it will
get there and again this has been the
story of deep learning in pretty much
everything we've tackled since uh the
beginning of of deep learning end-to-end
systems ultimately came to beat the
heuristic systems but it takes time it
takes to work it takes data obviously
massive amounts of compute
you know over time there's like
less and less conventional software more
and more neural net uh we're just still
software but it's you know
still comes out the lines of software
but
uh
more more neural net stuff uh and less
you know heuristics basically um
if you're
more more uh matrix based
stuff unless uh heuristics based stuff
so by the way the reason why this is the
case the reason why it works to replace
heuristics with neural networks with
data-driven systems is that the world is
always more complicated
than you can encode in any heuristic
that's why we use machine learning in
the first place because we can't just
program the algorithms that do image
recognition or speech recognition or
whatnot so the only representation of
this really complex world like the
actual underlying world that is so
complicated is the data and therefore
our best chance to create systems that
deal well with the world as such is
systems that actually learn from data
from the real world and that's why it
often works to replace the heuristics
with data-driven systems if you have the
data and if you have the compute which
tesla obviously does
we call the giant bag of points yeah uh
and it's like so you got a pixel and and
and
something associated with that pixel
like this pixel is probably car the
pixel is probably lane line um then
you've got to assemble this giant bag of
points
in the c code and turn it into uh
vectors
um
and uh it does a pretty good job of it
but it's
it's a
it's
if we want to just we need another layer
of neural nets on top of that to take
the giant bag of points
and distill that down to
vector space in in the neural net part
of the software as opposed to the
heuristics part of the software
so the translation of this is probably
if i understand elon correctly what they
were doing so far is sort of semantic
segmentation or or or pixel based pixel
labeling i can also imagine that they
estimated things like depth maps and so
on just from pixels but then as i said
before it was heuristics it was sort of
classical algorithms and these are i
mean classical these are advanced
algorithms right that take point clouds
that take sort of segmentation maps and
depth maps and all of that and turn them
into
objects these are mostly heuristic based
but very sophisticated algorithms but it
is clearly a good or a let's say a
modern move to ditch all of that and
also teach the neural networks to just
handle it until you have the the
semantic result that you want namely the
space of objects the scene understanding
graph
it's really outputting
proper vectors to
the
the cc plus plus control control code as
opposed to
the sort of
constructing the the vectors
uh in
c um
which we've done i think quite a good
job of but
it it's it's a it we're kind of hitting
a local maximum on the how well the c
can do this
um
so this is this is really this is really
a big deal
and just all of the networks in the car
need by the way whenever you hear him
talk about cnc plus plus code just
replace that with human human authored
code right the difference isn't
necessarily the language you use the
difference is more like who writes the
code and when he says cnc plus plus it's
humans very smart humans but still
humans that write the code out of you
know their thinking and whenever he says
neural networks it it's it's some sort
of a data driven systems which obviously
human author in the first place but
probably also is is as well implemented
in in c and c plus plus so
the training the amount of work done
with like we've written all this custom
software for training and labeling
um and do order labeling auto leveling
is essential
um
because especially when you've got like
surround video
it's very difficult to like label
surround video from scratch is extremely
difficult um
like take a human
such a long time to even label one video
clip like several hours
uh or the order label it
basically just apply a like heavy duty
uh
like a lot of compute to the to the
video clips um
to pre-assign
and guess what all the things are that
are going on in the surround video and
then there's like correcting it yeah and
then all the human has to do is like
tweet like say this you know adjust what
is incorrect this this is like
increasing increases productivity by
affect 100 or more
yeah uh so you've presented i mean we've
we've discussed this in the last video
that i did um about kurpati's talk and
this to me is is you know i think too
few people are currently doing something
like this essentially it's active
learning right it's sort of if you're
not sure about something ask the human
it has a slight twist on it in that they
probably always ask the human but they
suggest a label which is super powerful
especially in something like semantic
segmentation where you need to annotate
every pixel or you need to place
bounding boxes around many objects it's
really different if you simply have to
check and adjust a little bit versus if
you know there's there's a data point
and you have to place the labels
yourself i think we're going to see
quite a bit more of that in sort of the
the near future a lot of people are
already doing something like this but i
think still too few are it's not quite
in tesla's
primary mission direction of
accelerating sustainable energy but
it is a
an extremely useful thing that we can do
for the world which is to make a useful
humanoid robot
that is capable of
interacting with the world and all right
the rest of them talking about ai is
talking about the tesla bot which is a
bit more far-fetched i have to say um
the the tesla but just on its face it is
way more complicated than a car
especially if it is supposed to not only
you know be on the factory floor in
which case they just built like a robot
arm right these are like the most useful
things in effect on a factory floor but
if it's actually to sort of interact
with humans or in a human way navigate
not only unknown terrain but also
society potentially i mean this is just
this is just futurism at this point and
that there's really nothing we can
legitimately say about what's possible
what's not possible where this is and
obviously they like we don't we don't
have a prototype we just have like a a
human in a suit to demonstrate the tesla
bot so i will not comment much further
on that with respect to the tesla fully
self-driving system i want to say that
obviously you know for elon musk there's
always kind of
lovers and haters and i think you can
acknowledge both sides he is a bit of a
of a salesperson he
sells these things very well he always
promises you know next year will be
ready next year will be ready and then
they never are or he over promises
massively on you know how much cost you
can save and yada yada but then on the
other hand he also delivers a lot more
than other people deliver maybe that's
just kind of a little bit of
recklessness but also the sort of
optimism and momentum that he's able to
to to come up and drive and all of that
together i think just makes for like an
interesting person and i think the
advances itself are remarkable even if
you say other car companies are on the
track and whatnot tesla has done more
than all other car companies together
for the adoption of electric vehicles
yes you can debate whether or not that
in itself is a good thing but just to
say that it's not only
salesmanship there are also results and
i have no doubt that in the near future
we will see self-driving cars sure
they're not going to be accident-free
but i believe they will be much much
better than humans and the question is
simply is this next year in two years in
five years i cannot tell you but i'm
excited to see i hope you liked this
talk analysis interview analysis if you
want more of these things let me know
otherwise let me know what you think in
the comments and i'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no